si tu veux que j'attaque d'algo je
l'attaquerai sur autre chose c'est sûr
la façon dont elle a étouffer Paris et
qui gêne considérablement le théâtre les
restaurants etc parce que quand les gens
qui font vivre le théâtre et les
restaurants et les lieux de voilà c'est
pas que les Parisiens c'est aussi la
petite et grande couronne d'accord
et puis ils viennent pendant les
vacances mais la petite est la grande
couronne qui fait vivre le théâtre et
les restaurants quand ils ont mis une
heure et demie pour rentrer chez eux le
soir elles ont pas envie de se les
retaper dans l'autre sens si tu rajoutes
à ça la possibilité de te garer
l'impossible le prix du parking le prix
du resto le prix du théâtre ta soirée
elle est tellement cher que voilà donc
en fait on a elle a asphyxié tout ce qui
comptait de culture à Paris d'ailleurs
c'est devenu si tu regardes bien
Paris la nuit toi qui tourne tous les
soirs tu trouves qu'il y a 2000 endroits
où aller non c'est vrai voilà c'est vrai
[Musique]